[Music]
this is star talk sports edition i got
gary o'reilly with me gary hey neil
yeah gary you're going to take us
someplace
uh let me let me let me dredge my
memories from a cup pre-covert i think
this was yeah it's just it was really
two years
was there a world before coving did the
world exist
it feels like a lifetime ago but
only two years ago so back in february
2020 we released a show called stadiums
of the future now it's interesting
because the stadium we picked
hadn't been constructed yet it was still
in the process of finding itself now
that stadium is the sofa stadium and
that will be the venue
for this year's big game the nfl's big
game the 56th time it's taken place and
we're not allowed to say the s word they
get all upset now the thing is if you
remember neil
we actually sent you there in a hard hat
and a hi-vis vest to go and find out
what it was like
to see this thing emerge and what the
logistical challenges were and how it
came to be and the people that were
behind bringing it this is a very star
talking approach to sports and a stadium
because there's no athletes there's no
head coaches there's no tv dramas
there's just the guys and the girls that
bring this thing to fruition so if you
remember the sofa has this gigantic
transparent roof and it doesn't have
that bigger profile out of the ground
because it's been sunken because it is
directly underneath the flight path to
lax
so go on neil give me a thought of what
it was like to walk into that arena as
it was being constructed
yeah i remember that first there was the
bit of pride
when you speak to the engineers for what
it is they were designing for it
what kind of technologies would enable
and empower uh not only future teams who
play there but future visitors so it was
a delight i was i was geeking out
basically
and uh and i'd forgotten that yes this
this stadium is sunken into the ground
kind of like i think the rose bowl is
partly underground as well in pasadena
if memory serves and so that gives it a
much lower profile on the horizon
otherwise it just kind of sticks out you
know like a sore thumb but the fact it
has a lower profile and you're right
it's on
on the takeoff and landing path of lax
so
so they were i was gonna say they were
considerate for this no that's not just
being considerate that's being saved all
right there's probably some legal limits
surrounding that as well but just to
look at how they were attempting to
future proof this stadium and i was
there not knowing that it would one day
carry the big game
what do you mean the bowl that is super
that game
so so um no so i i was delighted and i
asked i think all the right questions
and yeah
we had a good time as as well as sending
you out into the in the great wild
of uh of the sofa stadium we had a guest
and this guest is from ibm sports he's
the chief infrastructure architect at
ibm sport a guy called ben brulette
and
he was involved in the construction of
the mercedes-benz dome in atlanta if you
know the atlanta dome it has this sort
of tessellated lotus flower roof that
opens up it's magnificent
and he he explained to us to to do this
and the same with the sofa you have to
be thinking five ten maybe even fifteen
years advance for technologies that are
going to emerge but that you are able to
adapt to otherwise you have to you've
got a stadium that doesn't work i mean
there are stadiums now that are probably
being constructed in the early 2000s
but as far as technologies that we have
now in the 20 in 2022 is more or less
obsolete there are helpful so
so gary there are two challenges there
so one of them is yeah you want to
future proof everything you do in all
construction but future proofing
involves
projecting
and the scientific word for that is
extrapolating when when data are
informing your future expectations it's
called extrapolating so you have a plot
of the way things are trending and you
say no let me continue the slope of that
line that of these parameters that i
plotted and go into the future and have
this this thing i'm building today be
able to accommodate this growth curve
that works to a point
the problem occurs and you're right gary
it's typically a 15-year horizon people
can be good if you if you invest brain
energy projecting five to 10 years out
15 years you know it begins to happen
you get discoveries and inventions that
come
out of
left field or come in from the end zone
whichever reference you're comfortable
with but it comes from a different place
it comes from a place that's not even on
the plot on the chart that you were
using to make those predictions and that
those are game changers for everything
so
you know i don't know what a good
example would that be okay here's one
how are you gonna this is not a big
challenge because we have accommodated
it but it's an example you want a future
kitchen and you say well what kind of
modern stoves are we gonna have okay
they might be electric so let me put the
stove near a power plug that'll future
proof it okay maybe there's some other
electricity that needs to go let me make
a conduit there to and you do all of
this and then a microwave oven shows up
okay
who ordered that you know that's not an
extrapolation of a modern oven that
involves heat and flames or or coils
it's a whole other technology so where
do you put that so modern kitchens of
course are designed to fit those
comfortably and nicely that was not much
of a stretch as far as construction
goes but you can imagine something that
would be completely transformative that
would make sofi stadium look like
something ant like like wrigley field
yeah i mean the thing is
they will want to leave
intentional space
to accommodate anything new and and the
hardware that needs to be in place for
that new technology to be productive i
mean the other thing they did was they
earthquake proof because it's downtown
l.a and things shake and wobble on
occasion shake and big yeah yeah they
they earthquake proof the whole stadium
now this is a big deal this is a 4
billion beginning with a b billion
dollar project i mean it is an
entertainment palette but just to be
clear i'm an astrophysicist you don't
have to extra explain
the number billion to me
no no no it's just in case people don't
understand my version of english and
they think i'm saying 4 million and it's
actually billion so um it's it's it's so
interesting and i if i remember rightly
we also learned take that as you say
extrapolate what might be coming along
before we quite got there but using what
we know now
we thought maybe augmented displays
for people in stadiums could be
something in the future so if you
imagine you you've decided you want to
be a defensive end you could end up
having a sensory experience that feels
like hitting a quarterback
yeah or or before you get there just
imagine you buy
a stadium experience from the nfl or
from the home team or from sofi stadium
and they'll sell you
the ticket at the 50-yard line 20 rows
up
and then you go into your augmented
reality room in your home
and you experience the entire game from
that seat
wow
then you know you have to go to the game
and then take that up a notch okay so
now you're saying
why be in the stadium at all
why not be on the field
and
you could be sort of a an avatar
on the field as players are running by
you because if you censor you have
sensors that monitor everything about
all the players which ibm currently does
or has the power to do uh if you do that
and i know where all the players i know
what their heartbeats are
because the coaches want to know that
when is it really going to bring them
out when are you going to put them back
in when have they recovered their oxygen
levels you i have all that information
yeah and information is power
information is money right so so now you
put me on the field i'll be i'll be
eating eating cheetos if sitting on the
line of scrimmage while the whole game
is going on we'll be eating christmas
second quarterbacks it'll be a dream
come true so this is
you want to also include the physical
experience of getting hit and i'm
yeah so does a person pay extra for that
well i
probably but the answer to that is
simply yes
anything like that it's
but that's it neil you see the thing is
this is where we take the show and as i
referenced before it only startup will
do this only star talk will think this
way too
yeah and so this is why we're
re-releasing this particular show from
two years ago to to stand on the
shoulders of this big game but to give
our audience
an understanding
of the environment they're in
that will sit nicely next to the
performances hopefully of the players
beautiful
beautiful so good work there gary and i
look forward to checking out the episode
again
today's topic
modern stadium design
and the tech
that informs it
so who do i have here i've got
ben brillet i pronounced that right you
did thank you ben welcome thanks very
much you work for ibm i do you design
stadiums well you got to title it global
chief architect for sports and
entertainment services that's a lot of
syllables to say you design stadiums
well i designed technology for stadiums
oh excuse me yes right yes i don't want
to i don't want to cause any fights uh
so yeah yeah okay all right so we got
we'll get back to you gary yes always
good yeah good to be here gary o'reilly
chuck hey
you're my people yes my sports people
my my my sports people so recently i
visited the sofi stadium just outside of
los angeles absolutely they're in the
middle of building it yep and i'm
looking at the numbers at five
billion dollars
wow since when do stadiums cost that
much they do recently
since 20 minutes ago just saying of 70
000 seats
opening summer 2020
and it didn't look like they're going to
be that big you're saying they're not
making it
i'm saying you're saying i was there i
flew over it didn't look like but anyhow
i'll tell you this much they better be
ready by august of 2020 because they
already said goodbye to the old stadium
last year yeah otherwise they're playing
in the football team they're playing
they're playing pick-up game in the
right parking lot oh that'd be hilarious
oh my god just like you can tailgate and
watch the game at the same time
yeah that's great so uh that stadium
houses the la rams and the chargers yeah
yeah and so
uh ben so i'll just get a little we'll
get back to that i get footage of me
visiting it uh but ben
how long has has ibm had such a thing
ibm engagement started really with the
atlanta olympics in the 90s uh oh wow
this guy's been in the state sports
space for a while so you were the chief
technology architect for the
mercedes-benz stadium in atlanta but
that was way after the olympics
absolutely absolutely so it had a really
different design they didn't have the
benefit of your brilliance no although
some of the fiber infrastructure
actually ended up being reused
oh really you mean recycled and reused
or no no it was still there still good
and you just absolutely okay well way to
save them some money so so how are you
combining this sports and tech at ibm
because in these stadiums where
big muscle football players play it
don't look like you have ever played
football in your life no i have not i
don't know so how do you land in that
pot yeah so
ibm is approaching uh technology and
stadiums really from two sides the first
is sort of the digital where we're doing
ai programs and how can we help coaches
make better decisions about players how
can we analyze yourself yep how can we
analyze data be able to
uh take a coach and put them virtually
after the game
in a vr room standing next to the player
and say can i understand better why he
missed that or why he made that can i
watch this from a 3d perspective why not
put him in during the game well
wouldn't that
coach on the field right yeah i think so
that's that tech is almost around now
you convert with only a few seconds
delay you can put someone back into the
space yeah and analyze that play almost
real time and that's where i come in
actually is that the limitation now is
the technology and the data bandwidth
available on the field how can we get
enough antennas enough kinds of radios
to be able to move that information from
the field to the stadium in real time in
real time to make real-time decisions
exactly and so i'm involved in all of
the physical infrastructure the antennas
the cell phone radios the wi-fi access
points the security cameras uh all of
the physical tech that makes the digital
tech possible so i just got i just got
to tell you i'm really feeling good
listening to you because i i let a geeky
life
but
it was early enough
in the geek timetable
that we all not
i because i was bigger than others but
most of my geek friends all got beat up
by by the football players right okay
until
the football players needed the geeks to
help them with their computer homework
there you go okay right so the balance
of power changed
and so now you are enabling
professional sports absolutely
and now you are like a patron saint of
what enables them to do what they do you
have now you have sports people as your
protectors yeah i mean we want that data
we want them healthy we want to know
where they were we want to know that
predictive insights into injuries that
means he's never gotten a wedgie that's
well that's but
that may have been yeah
uh yeah just watch yourself yes i got a
linebacker on speed there you go all
right but that is a cool thing because
you can just be like yo bro one line of
code and i can make it so that you
one right one line of code
that'd be a great name of a company one
line of code one line of code
that's all the difference so what point
do you are you brought in so i'm rich
and i want to build a stadium at what
point do i call you
the earlier the better right
so we started in atlanta when it was
still a hole in the ground uh literally
still there because the technology
particularly as we start to talk about
of course atlanta is a 4g stadium but as
we look at 5g
more damn
more and more antennas means more and
more wires to the antennas that's right
and so we actually have to bury conduit
in the concrete before it even gets
poured so you have to have a design for
that ready to go
right from there onto it to future-proof
it yes
why not wi-fi this thing
save on the wires
so
all of that wi-fi
more and more access points right and
every access point so while it's wi-fi
to your handheld device the access point
in the ceiling needed a wire that smoke
detector in the ceiling needed a wire
you have to get the more there's a wire
somewhere that's right for me
that's my outside that's right
in fact the more mobile devices the more
wires behind the scenes so in fact
wireless is just uh
it's a distance description
footage of me
at the sofa stadium right outside of
outside los angeles the la
the the chargers and the rams correct
correct both will play there that's
right and obviously
almost not on the show today
they're right unless they play each
other there you go then they do play on
the same day in the same stadium yeah
that'd be kind of cool i'll go to that
game
all right
so um so i i visited it and one thing i
couldn't
help notice is just the enormous roof
a lot of thought went into that roof so
let's check out this high-tech roof
what is that transparent roof made of
it's called an etfe system how
transparent is it about 60
from what i understand oh so what you're
saying is it uh
it'll block out about 60 percent of
sunlight that could come in that's what
i either reflected or do something else
with it that's correct okay so those are
60 foot by 60 foot grid areas i see them
and then what we do is we build that
frame on the ground outside the building
and as we load this diaphragm in place
we go ahead and put those in and we pull
the etfe system over time how long does
it stay transparent it'll taste stay
transparent from the time we finish the
project on not as long as birds poop on
it you've got a way to clean that off
there is a way to clean it
how you do that and they'll go up i
don't see any way you anybody's going up
to clean bird poop there is there is
access up there and there is a gutter
system up there to go ahead and allow
for washing down and also so you can
hose it off that's one thing we can do
as far as as far as the birds though is
also use a falcon air so you can
actually have falcons that come around
here to keep birds away
does that help i'm trying to be as smart
as this man that's right that's very
national geographic yes yes
all right you glad you turned up for
this show
all right so there's a little insight i
want to say window but i'm i've done it
now
on to what's going on in this this 21st
century stadium
what else could we build into a roof
like that because that's a massive
expanse
and by roof he means bird toilet
yeah so i mean
is it so are we going to have solar
panels
because california i think every new
construction has to have solar panels
thank god um
can we use it like a tv screen can
project things out what what could we do
to play with this and make it just yeah
i mean just a roof i mean you'd love to
right the technology for solar panels i
mean the problem is the weight today
right uh can you make it light enough to
be able to cover the surface and still
have it span that enormous distance
which it now spans we've moved from
stadiums where you used to have you know
limited site view seats to stadiums
where there's no such thing in the
entire place because these roof
materials have gotten so light that now
everyone can see uh from everywhere so
uh the more technology you want to put
up there of course the heavier it is uh
we actually had just to be clear heavier
roofs require more structures to hold it
up that would block your view
potentially a light roof you don't have
to hold up the roof you can stand
further away stand further away so
that's what you meant fulcrum yeah when
you okay i was just trying to follow
that okay comes a span
exactly so how much distance are you
trying to span how light do you need
that
material to be in order to make the span
so that you don't have a blocked view
how does a roof like that affect what
you would be able to do in the stadium
you know it's interesting the
in atlanta and presumably they'll have
the same problem uh in los angeles as
well the fact that these materials are
now plastics you know if we look at an
older building like if we're in the the
lower levels here uh concrete rebar iron
uh the rf energy of the city radio
frequency yes the radio should be clear
uh doesn't make it into your basement
here right whereas when you build out of
these new materials these
hyper-thin plastics transparent
materials uh one of the challenges we're
actually having is that all of the rf
energy of the city is penetrating into
the building now so and you don't want
that you don't create interference
absolutely yeah how can you deliver cell
service to 80 000 people sitting in a
space which need low signal strength
because they're not that far from the
antenna but when you want to not provide
them cell service wouldn't you want to
block their cell service and provide
them your own particular frequency
because then you can determine what
they're going to watch see
hear and how they're going to interact
with the stadium and other people
because you're the puppeteer uh
electronically at that point absolutely
absolutely that's who you work for what
are you
are you an ibm operative from
captain verizon sounds like you work for
a daz company a distributed antenna
system which is the
local cellular system in a stadium and
the problem with that is we want to run
our das in a stadium and not have it
leak out into the city and not have the
city leak in so these new materials are
really creating challenges and how we
can do that success can't you put wires
in it and turn it into a faraday cage
yeah you you could but
please
we would like to know about a faraday
has nothing to do with prisons or
anything oh thank god faraday is
credited with this so um if you have
something that conducts electricity like
wire or any kind of metal
and you surround yourself in it
then
electromagnetic energy cannot penetrate
that surface
because it tries to get through and it
gets conducted into the surface and it
never goes inside and if so for example
you can walk out in a lightning storm
and if you're surrounded by one of these
cages lightning will hit it will never
go inside your bubble and the aliens
can't read your thoughts that too
hence the the aluminum foil
it's just nothing more than an aluminum
foil that's really what it is
exactly what it is okay sorry go on yeah
pick it up
so
with these new materials the it's just
become very difficult to create the
separation that we need to deliver that
kind of service so that's meaning new
antenna designs new antenna placements
more antennas
in fact in atlanta we have a first of a
kind deployment of the cellular phone
antennas are actually under the seats in
the upper levels of the stadium wow
because what we want is very low signal
power to only go a few meters to the
nearby seats and it sterilizes your
gonads
well i don't feel a little warm right
now
that's so that you get strong signal
right don't you want that
we've just gone down in atlanta
we did a lot of testing
all right yeah a lot of engineering went
into making that work another
interesting fact that we don't think
about much here on the east coast but on
the west coast it is in every design
point what do you do about earthquakes
ooh can you earthquake-proof a stadium
yes so at the sofa tour that i took i
had to ask him about it let's check it
out
this bowl structure is a separate
element to the roof structure all right
and it's separated by what's called an
mse wall a mechanical stabilized earth
wall so it's panels that go in so if you
were to walk through the rest of the
stadium you go to a back
area that has about 12 foot of gap in
between so that this stadium can change
it can move independently you can move
independently and then the blade columns
support the roof structure that actually
go to butterfly caps and struts into
dead men and that acts independently
with isolators at the top that can move
up to 81 inches so
you can sustain an earthquake it sounds
like yes we can
that's the code for
the this the stadium can shake and bake
you can shake it it's got a little bit
of a little bit of movement to it it
does and you got it and you wouldn't
even know because as you walk in
we have a moat lid so there is a mode
that goes all the way around that most
people don't know a moat a mode m-o-18
m-o-18 crocodiles exactly it could be
it could you because i mean the history
of learning about earthquakes and other
sort of issues is
you don't want movement over here that
have to be felt in the rest of the
structure no right because that could
take down the whole structure correct so
everything can have some independence
right and then it just lives as almost
an organic
element and you have these
almost like these cut lines yes
expansions yeah yeah the usual
thermal expansions and things
so ben working in the mercedes-benz
stadium in atlanta just a few years ago
did they have to put in any sort of
disaster proofing if not earthquakes
some other kind of protection i mean it
has to be built for the environment
that's in right so atlanta is a very wet
very windy place uh you know the movable
roof is there because atlanta has quite
a lot of days when it's rainy um so they
can't play football in the rain anymore
in my day you couldn't even see the
gridiron that's how much snow would be
on the field they'd still play right how
many fans were there i don't know
with a baseball bat
that's right that's how tough it was
i know you're not apologizing to me
that's right yeah so all of the
facilities are instrumented throughout
so within the roof uh within the columns
that support it this uh structural steel
the structural concrete there's
instrumentation throughout all of it
which today is more wires that we have
to bring to be able to measure the the
stresses that are on a given piece of
steel when you say instrumentation you
mean diagnostic
tools absolutely so you always know the
structural health of your facility yeah
so in atlanta there are pedals that open
and close to move the roof and you want
to know the health of the pedal system
so all of that is instrumented so that
you know that it's in balance and all
the motors are operating correctly okay
so you're not so you wouldn't be taken
by surprise exactly anything was about
to fail yep
thinking about what you said about
footballers can't play in this rain
so when you or someone like you is
involved in design
in a stadium
who are you looking to please the owners
the coaches the players the fans
yourself why would they be why would
that be mutually exclusive no i'm just
wondering is there you know the owner
says i want it done this way and the
owner's the guy with the paycheck
therefore the owner gets what he wants
or is there even if that might conflict
with something else correct
i think it starts with the fans right
because because they're paying that's
right they're paying the owners
right they they are the owner works for
the fans that's right they're the source
of revenue for everything else that
comes after it and what you want to
deliver is a great experience for them
and with stadiums huge stadiums they're
getting bigger they're getting more
complex because you have to compete with
the fact that it's not that expensive to
buy an 85-inch television with that's 4k
ultra hd yep that's right and put it in
your man cave that's what i did all
right hey man
you're working against yourself there
so i did no that's that's got to be the
thought process of every owner yeah
how do we get you out how do we walk out
of the house right well you can give
crappier television coverage
so i missed that we got to be at the
game that's we're gonna show the replay
only at the game yeah well there you go
well we wanna do both right we wanna
have you have fun on the days you can
make it have fun on the days you can't
make it you wanna have everything uh
bringing together best possible
experience but the stadium itself is
really competing for that let me get you
out of your house in atlanta or in los
angeles to come in
to the stadium we gotta take a quick
break when we come back more on the
innovative designs of modern stadiums on
star talk sports edition
start talk we're back
star talk sports edition
gary o'reilly hey yep
former football apparently
you keep telling yourself that yeah
chuck yes who do we have here
batman brilliant brilliance thanks
none of us even knew that such a person
as you existed
the tech
geeky person
who empowers modern stadiums to do and
be what they need to be to satisfy the
fans the owners the players
all of the above the great and wonderful
oz of stadiums
what that is i mean we hope it's that
way right if it we don't want to be too
noticed right me right on
so as you know we're featuring my
footage from my visit to the sofa
stadium under construction and not even
built outside of los angeles it's great
because one of the landing routes and
takeoff routes from lax was right over
the stadium so you just look out the
window there it is very cool that's why
i know it didn't look like they'd be
ready when they said they'd be ready i'm
just saying
i'm just saying but a lot of late nights
coming up
there's the exterior design but there's
also what's going on on the inside and
as you said the user experience comes
first
that resonates with what i learned from
the designers of this stadium let's
check it out
so what is the oculus so the oculus is
actually the
the tv screens and or scoreboards or
everything everything that will be
announced world's largest scoreboard and
where is it
is it gonna be in the middle or
somewhere no it actually follows the
line of all this so right where that
green box is that hydraulic box imagine
about eight feet away from that
we start building sections of it
and we start building section and we
stack sections on it such as this one
too on this side as well all the way
around the entire bowl and then we go
ahead and put a strand jack simmer to
this assembly up here
and we introduce load we pull down it
pulls on the roof it weighs two million
pounds when it's completed with
components we assemble it here we
commission it here and we take it all
the way up you hoist it up and we hoist
it up so when you're standing on level a
you see a guy there on the yellow yeah
that's level eight and then level nine
above you'll actually be staring right
out of that oculus got it so you're
going to have those type of seats but
you can still see the field still see
the film
so that that was accessed for cheap the
cheap seats the cheapest guys out yeah
it seems to be there's an arms race with
stadiums now for the world's biggest
uh like jumbotron or spanx
no i haven't been to a game in a long
time can you tell
absolutely i mean that atlanta's the
current record holder so they're
they're trying to beat atlanta
absolutely over so far yep oh oh see he
he's he's like do you see him yeah
you're feeling it
right
his face got a little wrap a little bit
yeah he got a little little chest
beating going on right there
so now this will definitely be the
world's largest screen and or fan screen
in the world after it's done yeah so the
new oculus here has screen here and so
far and so far has screen services on
both
sides of the
circle so it's not just a single ring
there's display elements on both sides
of the circle that's hanging down oh so
oh it's a double sided inside outside
it's a kandinsky painting of jumbo
screens oh
kandinsky man he's damn yeah he's on
something to man
so i don't know who said that
[Laughter]
all right let's play the game here what
other tech
could you introduce to improve something
like this oculus
what could what could then take it to
another level because this seems as
chuck says a bit of an arms race
yeah i mean the the holy grail really is
uh to have vr players on the field right
oh my projected augmented reality more
than vr really yeah but augmented
reality players projected on to the
field we're still some ways away from
that but what would i do that's gonna be
so cool i don't get it so check it out
so an instant i asked
[Laughter]
do you work for ibm no
well i mean let's just take this example
if you are an atlanta fan
and uh your team is playing in los
angeles you want to be able to go to
atlanta and watch that game on the field
in front of you
in your home as a matter of fact they do
that right now oh so i could be
in the field they don't see me but they
run through me well you can have that
maybe you could also have just an away
game played at home right you could have
like to have viewing parties now for the
playoffs yeah yeah your team goes to
another city right so you all put on vr
and you're all in this in their style
you're in in their place but you're in
your stadium watching the game on
youtube oh yeah yeah so you're so here's
the thing as a stadium owner you got to
love this because that means everybody's
got to buy hot dogs and that's true and
they're soft drinks that's true and
they're not watching on the 85 inch and
not flat they're actually watching the
field just like a regular game a reason
to get out of home another reason to get
out of the house no get out of home and
go to the bar and put on you
because you know the truth is no
actually neil makes a really good point
the truth is if you bring that
technology to a stadium it will only be
a very short period of time before bar
owners bring that technology to their
venue okay they get a miniature version
of a mini version and then basically
you'll be more work for me you think
that works for you
he's like hey guess what i'm good right
so is that real is that i mean we're
really not not yet not yet the display
projections think about pokemon problem
uh pokemon go that's right yeah if they
can just show up in places so so we
could do it today with looking through
your phone right but that's not the best
experience you want to be able to look
at it in a seamless way so there's a
couple of barriers one of which we're
about to solve with 5g which is the
ability to get that data out of the
field real time uh recording uh what
they're really called voxels the
volumetric image data so that you can
project from any three-dimensional pixel
three-dimensional pixel
and get that out of the current stadium
so 5g will help with that where we're
following uh a little short still is in
the display technology so right now you
need something like maybe google glass
right i was going to say augmented
reality display to look at it eventually
we'll be able to project it in fog or
something like that you know that
technology is still a ways off but i
mean
they're working on it
yeah man that is so cool i mean like
just but in a way though but let's
let's let's let's play this out just for
a second now because see if i'm a nfl
player
and i'm smart
and i hear you say what you just said
you're no longer my friend that helps me
you are now my competition and now we go
back to where jocks beat the hell out of
geeks
okay
because the biggest regression exactly
because let's be honest
what you just said there
is one step away
instead of an augmented reality which is
basically the real-time transmission of
data
to
why do i need that i'll just create the
data myself and transmit it so that
you're seeing a game that is really an
algorithm that even though it may be
predetermined it's still a game that
happens right and you can watch football
nobody gets hurt nobody goes
no it's not john madden because see john
madden who you're playing whereas this
would be
would be an indeterminate algorithm
so none of the outcomes are
predetermined and you would see
well so one thing about if you do your
your integrations well and beautifully
often people won't notice it'll be
seamless
a seamless part of their experience so i
i talked about what's what's going on
that might be hidden or what might be
yeah um
part of the visitor experience that they
might not be thinking about yet they
benefit from it at so far stadium check
it out cool in modern times football
teams keep track of their players
and with the high-tech monitoring
systems and gps how far they've moved
uh will there be any sort of high-tech
sensor systems yeah and that can be
invoked yep
it's actually not gps based it's armed
based okay so we have a ring of
basically sensors around so when the
players walk out of the dressing room
they have a chip in their pads that gets
turned on basically when they act then
when they exit the locker room and then
uh within the playing surface basically
uh they track the movements they can
then figure out things like velocity and
top speed
and all that so so but that's not unique
to the stadium if everyone has a chip
in the modern nfl the league basically
mandates that system and plus for the
health and well-being of the players too
right right you can track how how far
they run how fast they run how much
they're on field etc that means you can
also measure
how fast they decelerate in a block yeah
like you're running and i can run at you
and i got your speed all the time bam
you go from 20 miles an hour to zero in
or whatever right right so ben why are
they using rf technology if 5g is
basically available
so it depends what is that sensor trying
to accomplish so on a high school field
you have gps you're out on in the air
you can see the satellites the gps
trackers will fit in their pads more
importantly the gps satellites can see
you the gps
now but that's okay
and indoors now you have again the roof
which is blocking those signals you need
to provide some sort of local system
that can now provide that location data
okay so so 5g is not a local system
that's it well 5g is a local system and
they're
even within the stadium locally
absolutely so to that technology of daz
that i mentioned earlier we have to
build our own 5g network inside of a
stadium to meet the density of people
who are there you know 80 000 devices in
well we might even call 160 000 if
you've got a watch and a phone right
devices in a small space now you need
dedicated electronics uh dedicated
antennas and radios just for that
stadium by itself but that tracking
versus making phone calls all different
kinds of 5g that are starting to come to
life and the density the number of
devices as we look at iot and really
those sensors are iot uh is just going
to balloon that's what iot stands for
internet of things so that's what that
that's what that abbreviates yes
internet of things things should never
be abbreviated yeah thank you it's not
important i was like this thanks for
clearing it up
stuff i don't know what it is
as a as i sit here and listen to you
explain that ben
my i'm looking at my mo my cell phone is
dating and out of date within two years
yeah
so how do we
future proof
what's coming that we can do
that you are
that you're going to be able to jump on
and utilize yeah yeah how about 7g 8g
10g it'll all be there
the way that we future proof in our
architecture is we say we don't have a
crystal ball the only thing we can do is
put more pathways for more
antennas
uh make sure that you have the ability
to put today you have one in 10 in this
room tomorrow you have two four years
from now you have four or five yeah i
got i gotta i gotta interrupt you okay
and back to the future two
which took place
in 2015
or 16 i forgot somewhere in our past
right now
um
back when it was made
people had fax machines okay that was
the thing oh that's cool that's how you
send
so they imagined in that distant future
that households
would have
multiple faction issues
of course so when marty was fired from
his job it was sent to him by fax and
every fax machine in his house out came
the thing you're fired and you say wow
that's the future right we'll have more
than one fax machine so isn't that a
little bit short-sighted to say let's
just put more of what we already have no
we're not so much putting more we're
putting more capability but just the
path we don't know what kind of cable
will go in it we don't know what kind of
antenna will be there so you assume it
needs a pass you need to have a spot to
put it right and that's becoming
particularly challenging because
uh architects also want their stadiums
to be beautiful right you want to
experience the technology but not have
to see it so you need to really design
in from day zero the ability to put all
this electronics there and be able to
hide it tell me about helmet cams that
would be another it'd be first
it would be interesting just to monitor
helmet concussion
the forces that operate on a helmet you
should be able to do that my iphone can
measure accelerations no matter what i'm
doing a helmet could do that too
absolutely okay so but not only that
just point of view cameras like suppose
i'm going to experience a game as a as a
fan and i can just flick on let me see
what the quarterback is looking at let
me see with the center let me see with
the wide receiver and that's their
camera
what's what's yeah how about that so
with with 5g we will be able to do that
especially in a sport like football
where you have a lot of room to put uh
the heavier batteries and the the camera
sensors things like that oh this is too
heavy yeah but well that's a baseball
player
but as a soccer player
the good news yeah you guys when you get
clipped on the side oh oh wait man
that's it i can't get up the white's too
much
you soccer players what the hell is
wrong with y'all well we got good news
for precious we got good news for soccer
football uh have you is that where my
team gonna win well with the 3d with the
3d volumetric pixel imaging it's now
possible
computationally to recreate any view
from an array of say 32 cameras around
the stadium it's like bullet time yeah
yeah like in the matrix where you can
get in the camera angle yeah so you as a
viewer could pick you wouldn't even have
to be limited to a specific helmet cam
you could pick the view right in between
the two helmets and have that computed
for you dynamically from the images that
are already taken that's pretty wide
that's badass right there see now once
again it seems like you're working okay
so this would be an see that's something
that you want to keep to an end stadium
uh experience right because
to be able to come and look on your
phone and see a completely different
game than you're actually watching on
the field why be limited to some
cameraman right who's parked on some
spot on the sidelines
you can actually curate your own game in
real time as you're sitting there let me
see that replay you know that's kind of
cool yeah you could end up you know with
twitch style re-edits of
we got to take a break can you hang
around for like the third second
absolutely because normally we just sort
of you know chew the fat but i want to
chew the fat with you in the room sounds
great okay yeah that'd be cool all right
this is star talk sports edition we'll
be right back
we're back star talk
we have a special guest brought in from
central pennsylvania where this dude
lives nobody's out there
well no he's here
he was the only one there
thanks for hanging out normally we just
sort of chew the fat this segment but i
want you there thanks why we chew the
fat sounds good yes there we go all
right yeah so
i just i'm curious about some
i'm looking at the rate at which stadium
design is changing and that always tells
me things
it says if the rate is changing rapidly
now we can praise any newly open stadium
but if the rate is fast it means in five
years that's going to be an old stadium
just like technology itself technology
itself yeah absolutely so so how do you
feel about this
i mean it's good news for me right
uh the more technical job security
security
uh but now do you build that into your
design yeah because because he said he
future proofs by putting uh uh conduits
and and places where you would put stuff
okay yeah i mean there's capitalization
terms for all these things you want to
be sure you get your money's worth out
of it you need to be able especially
when it's five billion dollars worth of
money yeah
uh but it is a big challenge what can
you do how far into that crystal ball
can you see and you know we make our
best attempts at it but you know
okay so
we touched on augmented reality now i'm
just thinking if we really throw it a
long way away
do we actually need stadiums
because you're going to sit there with
your vr goggles and i'll give you an
immersive suit so as you can actually
feel the hits yourself yeah while you're
satisfied that's too much right
that's too much depends you dial it up
or you dial it down down yeah yeah
can i dial it down to a relaxing massage
that's negative three that's not
impossible we're talking about we've got
to get people out of their homes we need
to you know our competition isn't this
this this it's getting people away from
their tv sets in this the arena
but
is it just gonna come down to let's save
the money and put it all into the fan
experience you know you you'd think that
would have happened with video gaming
but what has actually happened is that
e-gaming has now become a spectator
sport spectator sports absolutely
watching other people play their e-game
but in the stadium you go to a stage to
watch on the big screen
video games get played it's true don't
look at me like that yeah you're doing
it we're all sitting in this room
looking at each other the same way it's
like which is what the hell is wrong
with these people
is that gen x is that gen y is that
millennials let's get to the bottom of
this yeah who it is who's doing this
yeah the the the under 25 it is yeah my
son is totally into it and i was
completely 12. right and i was
completely against it
until i found out that uh these uh
so-called e-athletes
many of them have uh seven figure deals
yep and now he gets home and i'm just
like but get upstairs and play that
video game
get those thumbs up get those thumbs
moving boy what's your problem
don't read a book that's right
are you reading
oh
good reaction time right
so yeah
our fans
the whole thing here now are we because
stadiums were built to honor the
gladiators and the athletes now we are
seeing a shift away to the fan the
spectator the person who provides the
income as being the point of view that
is the most interesting
where can we take that where can ibm
where can the stadium builders and
architects of the future take that
yeah i mean the fans what we're trying
to do with technology is deliver
a better game through improved insights
into how the players are moving their uh
physio mechanics the uh coaching calls
physio mechanics i hope so okay
okay i like learning new words
okay all right
and help the coaches to be able to make
the best decisions that they can help
the players be able to get the most that
they can out of their own body to put it
into
an ever more entertaining game right so
i think everybody is benefiting you know
we talk about the greatest players of 60
years ago versus you know sort of your
mid-tier players today the mid-tier
player had so much more information
available to them to help them train
exactly the right muscle rest on exactly
the right rest day uh you know the the
level of play is just going up up up all
right so let me ask you this with that
in mind talking about the fan
let's talk about the owner for a second
because here's the way i'm thinking i
spent all this money
i got this high-tech stadium
how am i going to make even more money
off of all of this 5g
capable technology what's the business
model where's the business model how's
the money come back in here right i need
that money to come back to me so am i
going to be charged to see like
certain replays that nobody else can see
or i mean what cause you know no fantasy
wall are you gonna right there's no fan
experience that's complete without an
owner saying nah you're gonna have to
pay for that
i mean all of that is possible right you
can have uh you know premium subscriber
level features you can have entry
features you can have features you can
only get if you are actually there that
happens today a lot because of tv
licensing agreements we can do more when
you're physically in the stadium than we
can outside can i give an example of
that a really lame but heartfelt example
when i was nine
we went to the bronx zoo
and we we were very frugal as a family i
saw other rich kids they could buy
the elephant key
there's a plastic key and the elephant
nose sticks out and at every cage back
when alan was wearing cages there's an
information
recording and you put the key in and
turn it and you get a narration about
the animal right but you had to buy that
you had to buy the key right and we
didn't buy the keys so i would just
stand next to the rich kids
why is this black kid keep following me
everywhere i'm sorry so i so i
i felt
i didn't feel like i was a part of the
experience right and it didn't feel good
to me even though i paid we had paid
admission to the zoo itself
it was i i felt left out yeah just
because i couldn't afford it and that
was a visitor experience in 1968
67 that was its version of what you're
describing yeah
okay so picking up another elephant key
analogy by the way i still own that
elephant key just want you to know for
real for real i'll bring it in you did
get one the elephant in the room
the elephant in the room or the stadium
gambling
when you've got all of this ability to
stream and do stuff oh my god it's a lot
of money
yeah so now you're talking more money
more money
than any other oh my god gary you are
brilliant how do we get in on this right
now because okay shut off the cameras
let me take some real time betting
while you're in the stadium
that's a money maker shake it
it it happens a lot more overseas than
it does here we have stronger laws
anti-gambling yeah right
but if i've spent five billion dollars
to create my stadium entertainment
palace
i'll be pushing really hard to get the
gambling laws changed in the state of
which i without a doubt yeah sure every
state yeah
i mean we're seeing data that comes just
for fantasy football right so fantasy
football fantasy baseball the decision
making data that's available to you for
your own fantasy league is would
probably knock the socks off of a coach
from you know 1955 right to have access
to the kind of information that you're
not making 75 1985 that kind of dated
there so going back to your point what
else happens how does how does the owner
you the owner make money
i put a massive big
complex of theaters show movies
i have shopping malls i was about to say
that how why aren't stadiums when we
were about to come underway why don't
stadiums
have um multiple use built into it's
like the stadium sits empty for most of
the time this is the whole deal with so
far so far so fi is a great example okay
so okay so
all right so so far so a professional
football schedule today it's 16 games if
you don't go into the playoffs correct
okay so
most football pure football stadiums are
used 16 weekends out of 52 period then i
noticed 10 years ago 20 years they tried
to turn them into
uh conferencing centers and things get a
little extra money on the side but still
what are you doing hold your event here
maybe hold a rock concert okay but still
you're in a stadium right so with sofi
it has two teams interlaced so now it's
32 weekends
that's way better than
16 out of 52
but still you got another 20 weekends
when nothing's happening is the business
model so lucrative that you can go
unused for 20 weekends no you need to
drive that attendance up and the use of
your facility so in atlanta they have
also atlanta united the amazon mercedes
yes facility so the atlanta united mls
soccer team has games that are played
there also people that have really
driven up yep really driven up the usage
of the building um and then you get all
the immigrants come in they get
something to watch right right because
all the immigrants play soccer
absolutely every last one of them
they've put seventy thousand fans
in the united states yeah four mls so
yeah wow absolutely yeah it's a huge
dream i'm not an american amongst a huge
drop there's more i'm just kidding
it's like people don't care and then you
look in every bar and it is filled to
the brim right you know and
none of them are americans
atlanta's culture is changing with the
atlanta united actually the atlanta
united are driving fans into that sport
at a rate that is sweet yeah i mean you
bought walk by bars in atlanta and there
is an atlanta united flag there are kids
going to it fantastically okay all right
so
america might come around on this yeah
the soccer thing yeah yeah you're
getting there yeah but i think the
footprint of the sofa stadium i think is
greater than disneyland yeah well
including parking yeah are you for what
there is multiple disc four
what else is there
what else is that they're building in
the the multiplex hotels
to make it a destination area the area
becomes a destination gotcha and then
the game is just one other thing you do
something to do that you can walk to
yeah wow okay cool because there's a
finite amount of people that can go and
watch a game but they want to come and
enjoy the experience so you will build
fan parks outside
i got i have an obscure geeky
sciencey
comment okay if i may i'm ready okay
um
if you're charging a battery either an
electric car or any kind of
a rechargeable battery
the if it's dead and you start charging
it
like the first 20
happens very quickly
and then as the battery gets more and
more charged the rate at which it
reaches the top gets slower and slower
and slower so that last five percent
takes almost as long as the previous
all the time it took to get to that 95
okay
do you know why no okay i'm about to
find out
the analogy
is a stadium parking lot
because in a dead battery you have all
these electrons in the wrong place okay
they done served you now you gotta punch
them back to so that they can serve you
again they gotta swim upstream and they
gotta park
on the other side of that battery but
they can only park in pre-designated
places oh so
so if you're the first electron upstream
you park anywhere i'm by the door
so in a stadium if i'm early at the
stadium i can park anywhere i can park
within seconds
the later i come even if there is a
parking spot for me
it'll take me longer to find it
so that when the parking
is almost entirely full and only five
slots left it could take me a half hour
to find a parking spot after looking for
those spots that's why it takes longer
to charge the last part of a battery
than the first part because of the
parking lot problem yeah have you solved
the parking problems yeah we we have uh
smart parking systems smart parts so
yeah and
well we determined to sign we have a
sign parking predetermined we also have
smart parking systems if you've been
like in heathrow airport uh with red and
green lights over every single parking
spot so you can look down a hallway and
see if there's a
light hidden spots yeah signs that tell
what
green
you how many are left on each level
turns out this is a huge source of
pollution in cities too yeah there's
come people driving around but not just
in parking lots period yeah in every
metropolis
80 of all cars that are in motion that
are not taxis are looking for parking
yeah so this company's trying to solve
this now to be able to help you uh
there's some new deployments out in
europe of smart parking systems in
cities so that you can know where to go
you could just see it above all the car
and the green one that's right there yep
that's some little car that's hidden
behind the suv
don't get angry when it happens i always
flatten their tires
so now
how many people are now looking for a
space
and there's only one green light
no then no no we need it
and converge
lights break out right how fast can you
drive see this is la so larry david's
going to be going to be there
yeah so we can actually fall using
cameras we can actually follow your car
through the parking garage and provide
you individually appropriate signage at
every turn for where you should go smart
can you talk to the car turn left you
idiot well you can change your time they
can read talk to the thing and i'm going
to sit back like that you know that's
exactly that's where it
yeah
all is so final thoughts chuck what do
you have um you know i'm going to go to
a game uh and and probably be
disappointed because none of the cool
crap we're talking about is going to be
there he's not yet it's not happening
but he'll call it get his phone number
he'll call you exactly that's right
gary it's great i think it's brilliant
because everybody wins
the players are going to win the coaches
ibm could become the best football coach
ever
right all the bio data all the
telemetrics all the players are going to
win and the fans are going to get a
better experience so it's a win-win-win
brilliant
yeah what thoughts do you have at night
before you go to sleep about all this
i want to make sure that my son when he
goes to have he's four now when he goes
to a game that he will be able to have
the experience that he is imagining when
he gets there
so
his world
his world already he can talk to the
house
right and have the lights turn on he can
type because he just talks to his
computer the information the world is at
his fingertips
yeah 15 years from now when he's there
before i was running the house with his
abs yeah
alexa
take that dad
[Laughter]
yeah you better get some really good
parental guidance
you know the world that he imagines is
different than i can imagine and i want
him to have
a great experience that keeps his
attention and keeps him going so here's
what i look forward to because i think
about this all the time
um
i'd like imagining tomorrow's technology
for many reasons but including the fact
that if it's good enough
it will make everything i think as
modern today look old
so
in the future
i want the technology to not even be
anything you are projecting for it
i wanted to benefit from innovations
may i say out of left field
something you didn't even know was on
its way in
that lands in your lap technologically
and you say oh my gosh
that's a game changer and with that
there's a future experience for the
player the visitor the coach
that today we can yet imagine
sweet it'd be great
revenues
that's what i think that's a cosmic
sports
perspective
dude thanks for coming thank you very
much
thanks for coming all this way from
central pennsylvania
which is in the middle of freaking
nowhere it is all right chuck gary
pleasure is good i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist this has
been star talk sports edition and as
always i bid you to keep looking up
[Applause]
[Music]